most women initiate divorces I think
it's like 70% and and the majority of
them site ex exhaustion yeah but that's
because women are always exhausted you
know why cuz they love busying
themselves with
they do dude they always do
like h g how many CH how many women ring
that Bell behind you so I can start
boxing you no how many how many women go
like this uh uh the kids and I had to
take the thing and then we had to do
this and and okay and really the only
thing you have to do is the you
have to do but women will be like H you
have no idea I had to go find Uggs oh my
God I had to go get the the plants to
give to the lady because to say thank
you you don't even need to do all that
and then they'll be like you know
what I'm so exhausted from all the
that I made up I'm going to divorce my
husband yeah and we're the Bad Guy honey
I know you're joking but like what
percentage of you for real believes
that well no you would have to say What
percentage of women do I think are like
that no cuz that's a it'd be a
ridiculous it'd be a ridiculous thing to
think that even one woman was completely
like that but there are yeah I guess
you're right dude there are you're
telling me Oh God damn dude I
mean half of women are probably like
that
Christoper fighting words but you're not
like that I hope but like but like what
do you mean you hope you've known me for
seven years no no but but yeah I'm
saying you can still leave me but I'm
saying like because of exhaustion you
still leave me because of exhaustion
because but really what it is is you
went to Michaels too many times the
craft store you you stop doing that
dude that imagine after all we've been
through if that if that was like how you
rectified it in your head cuz you
couldn't come to grips with your own
like consequences that you face and
you're like you know what she just went
to Michaels too many times and left my
ass Michaels is a craft store that she's
going all goes to all the time and it's
she's not going to leave me because of
exhaustion because it's not no no no
because that's the women are
gatherers and they take a bunch of
and they gather and they got to
go out and get this stuff and well the
guys are the hunters but the women
gather it all together and before you
know it they're like oh man this is too
much I divorce you and it's not even the
dude a lot of women do it yes next
topic
dear Lord please help me get through
this in peace without strangling my
husband my sweet husband who I still
love amen dear Lord please let me get
through this in in
pieces Well here here's where I think
you're F but see but okay and I want to
hear this trust me I really want to hear
this but I am
so done with this conversation and go
ahead and no no no no I don't even mean
like moving on I mean like keep going
but like I think I am done paying
attention sure but I'm I'm but I'm I'm
being loving which would be a reason if
you did that consistently that women
would leave it talk to the microphone
and go ahead and what were you going to
say about the the flaws go ahead I want
to hear it well I'm just say your flaw
specifically is course over the years
cuz you know you have a thing with women
some deep seening issues surrounding
women babe
what um I mean without getting like too
Nitty Gritty about it but you have had
some misconceptions about women that
when I've of course heard them heard you
discuss them with me and in coup's
therapy me and the therapist are both
like this you like actually you have to
stop doing that Meme face all right I
just do it the whole time that you
actually believ that like when you said
Sushi gave you stomach AES and I thought
you were lying because you didn't want
sushi yeah because that's something that
you would do ah you know what dude that
me
stom bro